hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play amnesia
machine for pigs now we officially can't
encountered the pig monster and we have
discovered that this guy is the great
nephew great-nephew or his great-uncle
is either Alexander or Daniel from the
original amnesia and this guy has
actually obtained a sample of the grunt
and the he has continued his if his it's
great uncle's experiments in the madness
by creating a pig version of the grunt
which is totally awesome
definitely not horrific in any way but
we continue on we must press deeper into
the Machine for the sake of art for the
sake of our children we must bet I oh
boy oh hey wonder what's happening over
here boy we should give me up with my
boys hello oh I thought it was gonna be
a dead body in there chemical
transportation danger highly corrosive
highly flammable well if you say so I
don't know what you talking about
oh come on I've been all over the place
what am I supposed to do get into this
box with the highly corrosive in the
flammables yep apparently that's what
I'm supposed to do in the nest of eggs
it is cradled in his sweating hands it
sucks the fever loose from his body he
dreams of birds far above in the jungle
canopy a Jaguar coughing at the dawn if
you say so but man this guy built
something big here
I mean it's so big that he couldn't have
built it by himself not by a long shot
he had to have a lot of help and I
imagine this sort of congregation of
this church might have helped him in
this endeavor either that or I'm about
to go into non death mode
hey now who's out there
okay what's happening
why what happening
did I fall did I fall was that mean
falling I think I fell that is very
reminiscent of the original amnesia when
I fell down which everyone knows that I
did okay is this where I get exposed to
the highly caustic and flammable crap oh
thank you mister you know exactly where
I am find the entrance nearby right
floodwaters you say you know I've been
worried about this for a while now up in
the chair have ourselves a little
operation here wait I can actually I can
actually interact with that okay that's
that good have ourselves a little
adventure into the water wow that's a
prog in a battery Wow Wow yeah hmm
what's down here I wonder and I bet a
lot of people have been wondering the
same as I have when are we gonna get to
the equivalent of the water part from
the first amnesia because a lot of you
remember that the most terrifying part
in games in any game history was a water
part from amnesia it's some form of the
farm verbs Campbell cou compounds and it
positively reeks of the flu foul fluids
I have seen too often before it is
clearly a compound some volatile bastard
of to composite ingredients I should
wager I would find them close by if you
say so man but I got a bad feeling about
this
with the dark and the monsters and me
not doing too well yeah yeah yeah that
hi really you gotta do I've already seen
them I don't want to see him again what
the hell is that
how's your piggy piggy why was there a
piggy piggy here is this what why huh oh
that's good I guess
inflamed it is burning it does bleeding
from each hole fore-and-aft leaking down
my leg blood and excrement my lungs are
in my vomit what I passed clots of my
organs now onto the filthy stone drink
this he says and I did drink it I did do
that because of the changes they ripple
into me my teeth sneeze out and scatter
like mice in the dark I cannot find them
all gathered what I can push them back
into my grey gums and my fingers my
nails are all weepy and falling out
drink it he says it'll help the running
of the fever because not all of us can
take the change on the other table a
beast under the blanket I never wanted
to see that but he drank it too he
passed it under the blanket and I heard
it drink dear God Almighty
how can a man [ __ ] so much blood and
still live what even reading that
freaked me out what the hell was that
all about
what the hell okay is it's like a
pneumatic okay it's a pneumatic delivery
tube that's gonna send that off to
upstairs I guess good ok no button I'm
not doing [ __ ] dad thank you this is a
different this is different I wasn't
here before
why are they flickering
why they flicker
hello peekaboo my fine I'm going oh my
god dang it was a girl Tyler oh oh good
dog dog I didn't know there was monster
good god damn it
holy [ __ ] what the hell I didn't even
know I honestly did not know I turned
around and it knows coming at me Oh hmm
what the hell I didn't know I was
actually a thing oh my god I'm gonna
crap my pants so hard so hard I heard
that the monsters don't go away in this
game or at least that's what I was told
whoa oh my god oh oh yeah onto his
handsome oh oh my god just ha just um
get her next time we will use an equal
mix of embalm and shine olga and
dispersor no no just take him out you
could dump him in the river for all I
care Oh
oh all right that's cool and all but how
about never do that again
how about school how much go Howard
Jonah the holding pens great fantastic
[ __ ] amazing I love it so much I can
hardly cry you shut the [ __ ] up I'm not
in the mood deal with your ball
I'm nothing mood to deal with your bull
goddamn goddamn alright is there
something in here it's hard to tell cuz
there's no goddamn music I can't even
[ __ ] tell oh I think I'd rather have
music cuz at least I'd know he's dead no
do not startle or upset the acquisitions
Gaga alright good great good love this
my favorite is my favorite favorite ever
why is this it's a teddy bear this is
one of my children's teddy bears I'm
twisting its head off Oh took delivery
of another batch of imbeciles today
there are the sorriest specimens of
humanity I've ever seen no one asked
where they go to the authorities of
bedlam are simply happy to reduce the
overcrowding in their teeming stinking
halls we measure their skulls check duck
teeth would give them laudanum in to
pacify them they wait in line
livestock dull brown eyes in filthy skin
many soil themselves as they wait into
the manipulator they file in silence I
hear the hissing of gas I hear the dull
groaning his teeth are removed as bones
are reset I hear the pigs screaming we
have removed all the mirrors after the
process it is their reflections that
trouble them the most afterwards when
they sleep I walk amongst them my
children I whisper to their dreams you
are my children now I have children once
again in your forms imperfect will be
the engine to make my own blood flow
again well if you ain't the most insane
piece of [ __ ] I ever seen in my life I'm
going to go jump off a bridge into a
pile of over there place it in the
corner what
you think I speak Russian do I look like
an inbred pop sir who gives a damn what
it contains just set it down carefully
and leave me be
okay then that voice actors all right
let's not okay [ __ ] here we go
why you got what are you blocking me off
a screw you fine I'll go another way
wait there is no other way what am I
suppose was that always open I wasn't
open ah come haha and screw you game ah
ah okay I think that means a monster
well I'm not sure I can never oh okay
there's a monster yeah yep I'm going
away now I'm going away ah maybe there
isn't a monster maybe maybe
oh oh
ah
ah screw you oh oh I do not like how
this game plays with you with the
lighting uh where did he go I know he's
in there is that him is he hiding there
waiting to burst out behind the barrels
in tag Bay I don't know okay this is a
cogwheel it's not a monster
I saw him I saw him I did you can't tell
me I didn't oh you son of a [ __ ] oh man
oh you saw I thought I'd found a bog
look at the box interseting that buck
well immersion broken not scary anymore
what am I even looking for I even
remember
take me five freakin minutes ago two
feet in this game well is it oh shut up
I don't want to talk to you I don't want
to talk to me cuz I know it's me I'm
talking to because I'm psycho bonkers
crazy right okay Thank You mandus if
that is your real name anything under
the stairs I can't even get back there
oh oh
oh man I feel sick I feel ill Oh
how about no how about none of that none
of that my I don't trust you face I'm
gonna have it a lot during this game
okay whatever I need to stop being a
giant baby and I'm gonna start being a
giant baby again can I get through here
know it hurts hurts too much apparently
what is with that screaming it's like a
baby screaming in the distance but
horrific and awful and I don't like this
dad doesn't drink you just spit all over
my microphone but I don't care
what's in there what it's in there
that's another teddy bear oh oh oh don't
tell me that this guy's using another ah
don't you beat everybody Shh
everybody
more experiments with compound X took
the dog and injected it with strychnine
after the expected convulsions in
spasming it died just after midnight I
immersed the body in a large tank of
compound X and introduced an alternating
current via induction coil for a period
of three and a half minutes partial
return was induced however damage
incurred prior to death was retained
upon revival meaning the dog continued
into an acute acute state of spike
kaneen poisoning until I put a bullet in
his skull but drowning perhaps yes it is
after all known to be the kindest of
suicides if one were to drown replacing
the fluid in the lungs with compound X
should theoretically be perfectly
possible as a revival method Wow
you're kind of messed up I like that I
like that okay now wait a minute wait a
minute I was just here
no no no no no I was just here what is
down here something horrific I'm willing
to bet something horrific man okay oh it
led me back to where I was supposed to
go okay alright then good I got this
thing whatever it is I don't know do I
need one more thing I don't know
what is that I hear that what is that I
hear something it's clicking what is
going on
I hear something I just don't know what
hey I can move this here point over that
way okay okay I remember there was a
note that said after I did that Oh
perhaps I can find another way I'm
probably trying to find some way to melt
it off with acid or something I don't
know but I got I got the two things is
there another thing that I need I I
really don't know there's only two
pneumatic tubes so I'm only guessing
that there's just the two hi
uh-huh I really don't know was there
something else that I needed down here a
Doozer so switch I need to flick is
there oh no no that's the thing that's
the thing that's the exit oh oh here
okay guy heard the static I just didn't
know where it came from I was so
confused sorry that took me way too long
I'm a giant idiot oh no I'm I'm so smart
whoa
okay ding done whatever the hell this
crap is it's gonna do me a lot of good I
have the compounded hisses and steams in
its container like a living thing which
is jelly to burn and corrode the
container is made from glass a strange
choice unless there's some particular
reason why the metal that pervades
everywhere else cannot be brought into
contact with this so-called compound X I
should investigate further for clues all
right let's put this on the lock and see
if we can't get out of here let's just
smash it right over it who gives up Boop
stop flickering uas OOP gotcha
did it I'm a genius best best ever it's
not working why what am I uh uh
uh-oh
what maybe I need to shine the light on
it yeah suck on this oh my god you're
kidding me right
holy crap I didn't know that was the
thing oh okay that was weird
but whatever okay my visions going oh no
I've gone closer shut up I'll go at my
own pace how I want to go you shut up I
will smack you and your dead face over
and over again ow ow I hit ya hit harder
this leaking world the bottle of gin was
empty sleep seemed impossible above the
skyline of London he could only see the
temple rising into the smog whatever you
say man whatever you say this [ __ ] up
game is getting worse and worse worse
and worse love it
ow I fell how I fell harder oh no oh no
oh no I'm in the sewers oh why did I go
into the sewers that is a human skull
Oh to be or not to [ __ ] off okay
so anyway that's all the time I got for
this part so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you
in the next video
dude holy crap
oh let me out
teddy bear